welcome back earth day is thursday
and subaru of las vegas is all about
protecting our environment
[Music]
you can do a lot of things to help the
environment maybe plant a garden
perhaps grow a subaru
[Music]
alright a little sun and i uh i should
probably get out of the way
it worked this is amazing it worked
all right that's a little tv magic but
here at subaru of las vegas they're
doing some great things to help the
planet it's burton hughes general
manager
of subaru of las vegas good to see you
good to see you jc and hey we're getting
low on inventory i need you to grow some
more cars like that i'll get on i can
grow some more
burton a couple of things about subaru
las vegas one you guys love the planet
two is you love your customers what are
some of the things that you guys are
doing to help preserve the environment
you know obviously uh we are definitely
in love with our planet uh as you can
see love
our national parks subaru is the largest
single corporate donor
for the national park foundation and we
just like getting out there and doing
stuff in our community that helps
preserve it
burton i feel like i'm saving the
environment just sitting inside of a
subaru forester
yeah you know subaru for for years and
years they've been focused on the
environment
by building partial zero emission
vehicles this is one of them
the exhaust fumes coming out are cleaner
than the air you breathe in downtown los
angeles
wow and does this have the special start
stop feature on that
how does that work it does so the stop
start is amazing you come to a stop
you have your foot on the brake the
engine quietly just silence goes it goes
dead it's it's silent
and then when you lift your foot off the
brake the engine starts up and you take
off
and it saves gas it saves emissions it's
amazing you're
so when you're sitting in that bumper to
bumper traffic on the 15 or 215 you're
saving the environment because the
thing's going to turn off
absolutely now talk to me about the
engine size because we've gone with a
smaller engine but it still has a lot of
power
it does subaru has gone from some of the
models having six cylinder engines
and they've reduced that to four
cylinder with turbochargers you have you
still have the power
but you have lower emissions and and
higher fuel mileage
i could see myself driving this thing
across the country maybe through
yellowstone park this summer it's it's a
beautiful car
now there's something here at the
dealership i've always wanted to see you
a very special fish tank
350 gallons of salt water and we've got
so we have an eel in there we've got a
little mini shark it's amazing
what happens if you open the door that's
what we scare the kids with but
no it doesn't it doesn't all come out
let's talk about earth day i know you
guys have a lot of special things
planned what are you planning for earth
day
so this thursday subaru of las vegas and
get outdoors nevada we're going to be at
exploration peak park
and we're going to be cleaning up the
trails and cleaning up the park it's
going to be a lot of fun
then on sunday we're going to do
something really fun
right out here in front of the
dealership we're going to clear out all
the cars
and from 10 a.m to 2 p.m we're gonna
have an earth day
farmers market and we've invited a whole
bunch of
people to be here to to bring their
wares and their food and all that fun
stuff
at farmer's market's going to be awesome
on sunday call subaru of las vegas at
or 702-495-2100 them online at subaru of
las vegas dot com
and remember their special offer subaru
love strikes twice
certified pre-owned event happening now
through april 30th
zero percent apr financing on select
2021 models
for well-qualified buyers las vegas now
we will be right back